welcome back to biomel and python in
this lesson we will speak about data
wrangling and visualization in python
before we begin let's review what should
have already been cleared up from the
first lesson and address some of the
common issues that people face a lot of
people come to the lessons and they
start with installing a developer
environment
or trying to figure out where am i
actually going to run this code and so
several things that we discussed in the
first course in the first lesson
we talked about different developer
environments like visual studio code
pycharm online
notebooks like colab jupyter notebooks
and then we talked about some of the
requirements you have to install python
on your system you have to install these
packages pandas and numpy
so first of all how do you install
python on your computer you have to
install python and check that it is
installed correctly so sometimes you
will have it installed but it might be
installed in a different portion in a
different folder structure so you have
to be able to find it there are several
different ways to do that you can use
installation to pip install or sometimes
even to a packaged install called conda
might make some of the installations
simpler because it can install
everything at once
now you can check that it has been
installed for example if python is
already installed on your mac computer
you can simply type python3 inside your
terminal and that means you can start
giving commands in python just like you
would if you were writing a script
sometimes you can also check what all is
installed what version is installed so
try to look for those things on your
computer
so then we talked about installing
developer environment so for example
here you can see a developer and violent
environment in visual studio code
what this environment provides you with
is ability to
write correct syntax to make sure that
you have everything installed and it
will provide you with some suggestions
you can also check different aspects
like your syntax
debugging your code and storing all of
the objects in a format that you can
easily find and explore your active
objects inside your project
so then in the first lesson we also
learned learned about how to use some of
these important packages that allow us
to work with matrices and data frames
and so these packages have to be again
installed on your computer so sometimes
if something's not working and it's
giving you an error you don't have
pandas what is pd what is np that means
you have not installed it so besides
python itself make sure that you install
them again use that using pip install or
conda so you can install all that and
then you should be able to load data
and explore that data and manipulate
that data using different commands
now we also showed how to use jupyter
notebooks and we showed it on google
collab this is a very useful way to
share your code with different
explanations images you can
do styling inside the text in between
the portions of code and even add videos
but remember the session is running on
the cloud so anyone getting your
notebook would also need to have access
to the exact same files that you are
using so this is an example of the full
notebook on on google colab and that
notebook link is in the first lesson so
you can just open it
copy it over to your google drive now
you have to make sure that you've got
the right files how to make sure that
you have the files
first of all if you use any kind of a
file and you want to
run it on google colab the best way is
to create a repository on github
github allows you to get access to raw
files so right here you can see that you
can create a new repository and then you
can load so right here you can see that
is the actual location of the file and
it has to be the raw file so you have to
provide access to raw file just like you
can see in the screen above so after you
have placed the file or have gotten the
link to the raw file you can load it
into your
code so what does this file actually
look like we talked about two different
types of files one file as you can see
here is a table another one in the
introduction to python is a series of
strings or a string object that you can
manipulate with
other types of methods but here we're
going to be talking a lot about these
tables and the tables
have column names they have row names
and then they have numeric data and so
when you load your data in python you
want to be able to make sure that you
assign different parts of this data set
to different
objects for example here you have the
full data set loaded from csv
and so when you load it from csv you
have to specify the separating symbol in
the csv
and then you can check what is in my
data and so there was also a an example
notebook of how to go through these
steps and try out different types of
data txt csv and different separators
inside those formats
now once you load your data there's
essentially a way to start assigning
different parts of the data to different
objects for example we can create an
object
as you can see here we can call an
object by its name by a column name or a
row name the column names
should be in the header so it's
important when you're loading that your
header is assigned once your header is
assigned you can call any name from the
header like you can see df.id df tree
you can just call them by name
or you can also use
a way to call rows for example you can
see df.i lock that will give you a
position so you have to specify the
actual position of that row and the rows
start from zero so zero one two three
etc so dfi lock one would be specimen
two you also can specify this first
column to be the index column so the
header is on top the index is your
column and so then you can call these
rows by name like specimen two specimen
one or others let's see how to apply the
syntax to the challenge of visualization
there are three different types of
visualizations that we will talk about
in detail bar plots box plots scatter
plots later on you will also be able to
explore other types of plotting that are
going to be useful for this kind of data
so what kinds of plots are typically
used when you have categorical data
when you have for example
samples and what types of samples they
are so for example control
condition one condition two those are
groups and then sample one simple two
sample three sample four etcetera to
organize your data for example i want to
just select
controls
and see all the samples in their data
you can use what's called crosstabs
when you have data that can be
summarized by such groups you oftentimes
want to see distribution mean median and
variability within each group and for
that you typically can use box plot so
it's a combination of categorical data
and numeric data when you have two types
of
numeric data you often times want to
compare them and that is most useful
with scatter plots we'll talk about
scatter plots a lot in some future
lessons and finally bar plot spar plots
are typically the very basic type of a
plot so you want to maybe show how one
gene is expressed or how multiple genes
are expressed compared to each other so
we'll talk in a little bit about how to
do that
so the first
type of visualization we'll talk about
is a bar plot in pandas this is actually
done in a very
neat way
pandas will utilize another package
called matplotlib which is a library of
visualization in python and here you can
see that just simply calling your object
so remember that
pd is pandas pandas has a function so
for example plot is the function then
what type of a function bar and then you
say what objects and what settings would
you like to use and you can write all of
that out in a single line as you can see
right here one line is just making this
plot with the title
with the rotation of your sample names
and calling a title giving a title
specifically to this uh
plot so then
you can also sometimes realize that the
scale of your bar plot is not good for
visualization so some
genes will have
scale that is very different for low
expression very small for high
expression very high so how do you
normalize it so that you can actually
compare them one way to do that is just
to adjust the scale so instead of
plotting in true scale you plot in
logarithmic scale so you can see that's
log e equals true so it's logarithm of y
the y is the axis y
and then that will be scaled to
logarithmic scale and you can also
modify your plots for example rotating
the titles of your x-axis is just rot
rot and you can also give titles so some
additional things you can add to the
plot sometimes you would like to
look at your data from a different
perspective for example transposing your
table so instead of plotting how one
gene is expressed in different samples
you want it to be
a gene
across samples right so for that you can
use transpose the command is just dot t
so you can see all of this information
just again fits into a single line and
then finally sometimes you want to
compare them to each other and maybe
they're in different scales so you don't
want to put them into one single plot
and so for that you can use subplots
equals true another type of
visualization is a box plot so again you
can see pandas plot and then instead of
bar here you write box again you can use
all of the same settings and calling the
right objects inside including
logarithmic scale to make those box
plots more visible again it's a typical
problem that we will address in our
future lesson about normalization and
scaling
now oftentimes you want to use box plots
like we said in the beginning to
actually organize the data by group so
we're not interested in a box plot of an
individual gene but we're interested in
averages of genes across different
groups so in the exercise given to you
in the lesson you will find that you can
read a code where by group you can
summarize your data
by
samples organized into groups and that
is done
with this function group by so you group
by so first you prepare your data and
then you again add this function for
plot
and then you will have
a box plot and there you will also see
an exercise for density plots which are
kde
and those will produce some density
plots similar to box plots but in a
different visual format in the lesson
what you will see is the syntax for
visualizing the data
you will get a coding challenge where
you will try some of the different
visual outputs and then try to fill in
the blanks in code that has to be fixed
for it to work
then you will receive a full interactive
notebook that you can view and you will
see there an assignment so to submit the
assignment just copy this notebook over
to your own google drive
write out the code with whatever
assignment you got and then share that
with one of your mentors in the program
so again
how to learn to do this on your own you
learn the syntax different types of
plots why are they useful and how to use
them
then coding challenge so how to write it
yourself and try it
then you will get the interactive
notebook and then you submit the
assignment that's it for now we'll see
you in the next lesson